if you're organizing an event or run a
local group then the chairman of
rochester district council wants to hear
from you
councillor simon smith was elected by
his fellow councillors to be the
chairman of rochford district council in
may
and since then he has been on a
whistle-stop tour of the district
visiting events and local groups
he said
being chairman of the council is hard
work it keeps you very busy but it's so
enjoyable it's a real privilege i have
already met so many people who really do
help
create the wonderful community that is
the rockford district
and i'm looking forward to meeting many
more people during my year in office
if you're organizing an event and you'd
like me to attend i'd be more than happy
to try to come along
councillor smith represents the rayleigh
white house award on the district
council and has been a councillor for 11
years
he has lived in the rochford district
since 1990
and has also served on rayleigh town
council
the chairman recently announced his
engagement and as a father to stuart 22
and sarah 17.
he has worked as a teacher at swain park
school in raleigh since it formerly
opened opened in 1997
and prior to that when it was the swain
school
during his year in office the chairman
will be raising money for several local
charities and is set to host lots of
events
so if you would like the chairman to
attend an event you're organizing or
visit a group or organization that
you're part of
please get in touch with julia mitchell
the civic officer
you can call her on zero one seven zero
two
three one eight one double four or email
her at
julia.mitchell at
rochford.gov dot uk
uk
welcome back to side two
being chairman of the council is a busy
job as councillor smith visits a host of
events and organizations across the
district
already this year the chairman has
attended more than 50 events as well as
raising money for local charities across
rochester district
one of the highlights of the chairman's
year is his civic reception which took
place in july in the gardens of the
council offices in south street
councillor smith welcomed a host of
local community groups and organizations
to the reception
it gave him the opportunity to thank
those who contribute their time and
effort to the local community as well as
raise funds for his chosen charities
more than a hundred guests enjoyed
first-rate refreshments to the sounds of
beautiful background music performed by
an instrumental ensemble from the essex
concert orchestra
later on in the afternoon guests were
entertained with music from films and
shows by the swain park school choir
a return by last year's highly praised
young caterers ensured a mouth-watering
spread for guests
the menu was prepared by pupils from the
king edmund school who were invited to
provide the catering for the occasion as
part of their study for the b tech
national award in hospitality
the chairman is hosting plenty more
events during this his year in office
including
eyes front a veterans afternoon show
starring arla sinclair and filmmaker
patrick king
this will be at the swain park school
sir walter rally drive rayleigh essex
ss6 9bz
it'll be held on sunday the 23rd of
october at 2pm
and you can contact julia mitchell
on zero one seven zero two
three one eight one four four
or
julia.mitchell
rochford.gov dot uk
over the last 18 months rochford
district council has been part of a
project with other south essex local
authorities to help businesses access
advice and funding to lower their carbon
emissions
the low carbon business program helps
small and medium enterprises known as
smes in south essex reduce their running
costs by cutting carbon
many smes have already received help and
support and esw chartered accountants in
rayleigh is just one
esw chartered accountants is a young and
dynamic firm which has enjoyed rapid
growth since the practice was
established in 1996.
they were introduced to the low carbon
business programme through a rayleigh
and district chamber of trade meeting
their existing boiler was old and
inefficient and esw hoped they could
replace it
following a visit from the low carbon
business program who explained they
could apply for a grant and how the
process would work esw chartered
accountants decided to go ahead with
replacing the boiler
audit and accountancy manager amy woods
said the assistance provided by the
low-carbon business team made the
application process very straightforward
a small grant of 880 pound funded by the
european regional development fund was
awarded to purchase a new a-rated boiler
which is 90 efficient to replace their
existing approximately 70 efficient
boiler
the boiler replacement should save the
business 253 pounds per annum
esw are one of the many businesses both
in the rocha district and across south
essex that have been helped by the
program
keeping the running costs of your
business as low as possible is crucial
at the moment
we've all seen our energy bills and the
cost of materials increase but it's
often difficult to know where savings
can be made and to decide whether an
investment is worthwhile
this is precisely where the low carbon
business program can help
rob robinson business energy advisor for
the low carbon business program has
visited hundreds of small and medium
enterprises across south essex
he said quite often all that a business
needs is some impartial advice
there are plenty of things that can be
done with little or no investment and in
many cases it helps to have someone
question why you do something or to
highlight the costs attached
if a business wants some advice all they
need to do is contact us and arrange a
convenient time for me to visit
we are fully funded by the european
regional development fund so there's no
cost to the business no commission is
taken and there are no hidden agendas
the low carbon business program is
available until december twenty twelve
to find out more or terrain to arrange a
visit call zero one two six eight
seven five eight
four two three or email
info
at low carbon business that's all one
word dot org dot uk
if you want further information about
the program businesses they have helped
or any of their frequent events visit
their website at www dot low carbon
business or oneword again
dot org dot uk
the council is introducing a series of
improvements in the way you pay for
parking across all car parks in the
district during october
we've purchased new pay and display
parking machines that will offer a
variety of payment options and give
motorists better value for money
these are the main changes
payment by credit or debit card
the ticket machines will allow you to
pay using a chip and pin verification
facility the same as when using your
card for any other transaction
waive and pay
the machines will also accept those
debit cards that have a chip fitted
allowing contactless payments
this provides motorists with a speedier
transaction for small payments without
the need to enter a pin number
payment by mobile phone the machines
will display full details explaining how
to pay using your mobile phone
you'll also be able to receive a text
message to remind you that your ticket
is due to expire and allow you to top up
your ticket should you be delayed in
returning to your vehicle
linear charging
this means that if you don't have the
exact coinage and have to overpay for
your chosen tariff you'll receive any
extra paid as time on your ticket
this will be calculated relative to the
next time band and will mean our
customers receive better value for money
following requests from customers and
traders and feedback from our customer
survey last year the council has decided
to reintroduce the half-hour time band
in the past when the half-hour time band
was offered many motorists
underestimated their time required and
incurred penalty charge notices
so the facility to purchase a half-hour
ticket will be reviewed after six months
now the new parking tariff will be this
up to half an hour 40p
up to 1 hour 80p
up to 2 hours 1 pound 40
up to 3 hours 2 pounds
up to 4 hours 2.40
up to 5 hours 3 pounds and all day will
cost you five pounds
the car parks
old ship lane car park in rochford is
restricted to parking for up to two
hours
webster's way and mill hall car parks in
rayleigh are restricted to parking for
up to four hours but season ticket
holders are permitted to use these car
parks
the approach car park at the rear of
raley station offers an all-day ticket
only
all other council owned pay and display
car parks have no parking time
restrictions
annual and quarterly season tickets are
available for all car parks priced 800
pounds and 240 pounds respectively
season tickets for the approach car park
at raley station are 700 pounds and 200
pounds
and don't forget with the continuation
of the council's free parking on
saturday afternoon scheme a play and
display ticket need only be purchased to
cover you up to 1pm
if you arrive after this time you park
free in any of rochford council's pay
and display car parks
the council will continue to offer free
parking on sundays and bank holidays
the council has made a number of
improvements to the parking facilities
in the past few years which have
benefited motorists and traders alike
including ensuring all car parks are
park mark accredited and we will
continue to look for opportunities for
further enhancements
full details are available on the
parking page on our website or by
calling transportation on
01268
798 606 or 798 608